Jennifer Toth author of what happened to
Johnny Jordan the story of a child
turning violent where is he today he's
in prison an adult prison facility
outside of Toledo he's serving uh more
than a life sentence what's that mean
means that he'll be at least 70 before
he's considered eligible for parole but
his attorney and other people believe
that by the time he spent his entire
adult life and most of his life in
prison he really won't be eligible for
parole and how old was he when he
committed his crime he was 15 years old
how old is he today today he's 21 he
just did his 21st birthday and his
attorneys say that if he had been three
months older he probably would have
gotten the death penalty how many hours
do you think you spent talking to him
well I still speak with him at least
once a week on the phone for the prison
a lot of time and I spent weeks out
there at different parts over the five
years I spent writing the book I would
spend about five or six hours a day
interviewing him for to expand why did
you want to do a book on Johnny Jordan
jr. no he's not yeah he's a junior he is
junior his father is Johnny Jordan's
senior that's a difficult question I
really wanted to look into what was
going on with these kids who apparently
showed no remorse and had no seemed to
show no emotion after committing these
horrendous crimes but what what really
hooked me on this case was that
Johnson's the the victims of this crime
because I thought I really sincerely
believe they deserved better they
deserved an answer to the questions they
were looking into why this child killed
at least they and they deserved a real
attempt to look into what happened here
and I was also angry that Children's
Services was trying to cover up what
really happened and that nobody was
looking at this seriously
there was a reason
behind the murders and I think that to
look at them in a straightforward manner
is the only chance we have of preventing
them and the Johnsons deserved that mr.
Johnson died before reform was ever
really implemented or even even thought
and I think that his quest was something
I wanted to continue who are the
Johnsons the Johnsons were an elderly
couple in rural Ohio and they were
Fayette foster parented dozens and
dozens of children over the years and
johnny was about 15 when he was placed
in their home they were come Bedard to
him than anyone had ever been to him he
liked them so much that he wanted them
to adopt them but one evening in late
January he walked into the kitchen where
his foster mother was preparing his
favorite dinner for him and without a
word he bludgeoned her to death
and then set her on fire and it was one
of the most horrendous and inexplicable
crimes that Ohio has ever faced because
nobody knew why he did it not even
Johnny in fact when he was arrested he
told detectives I don't know why I did
it why it happened she was a nice lady
she didn't deserve this to happen and he
was also appalled that he could watch
her bleed to death
and not feel anything he knew something
was wrong there what home what what
number of foster home was Johnny stay at
the Johnsons
this was his 19th foster placement and
he had been through 19 and five years he
had also been through a very poor family
environment but he really wanted the
Johnsons to adopt him and he really
wanted to stay there and he did not know
what triggered his rage he knew he woke
up with the churning in his stomach and
a feeling that he was going to do
something bad but he had no idea that he
was going to commit this crime
the Johnston's lived in exactly what
spot wood near what town they lived and
Spencer Township which is just outside
of Toledo it's a very rural area a very
small population very little crime and I
think that that this was also
interesting to me because I wanted to
show that these crimes are going on
throughout the country not just in urban
areas but in rural areas and in suburbs
and you know it crosses all sorts of
lines economic social everything these
kinds of crimes are really increasing
throughout the country where do you
personally live I live in Maryland and
Silver Spring Maryland just outside of
DC how did you find this story well I
had been hearing from social workers and
teachers about these these kids without
a conscience
these ticking time bombs and I was very
dubious about it so social workers
present me with a number of different
cases throughout the country that that
sort of fit the characteristics that
they are talking about and one of those
cases was this case the Johnny Jordan
case and then I called out to Ohio I
talked to mr. Johnson I was very moved
by by how he felt about this crime I
can't say that he forgave Johnny or in
what way he forgave him but there was
this lack of in dicted Ness
he seemed to think that he and his wife
and Johnny had all been wrecked by the
same storm and he really didn't he
really felt very angry or resented that
he hadn't been told of Johnny's past it
was what had happened to Johnny that he
felt most angered by at the same time he
clearly didn't embrace Johnny anymore
and when I talked to Johnny Jordan I
felt that I felt like I had more anger
towards him than even mr. Johnson did
and then when Johnny walked into that
room the first time I interviewed him
and I realized this was a child who who
couldn't look me in the eye he was too
shy to look me in the eye and he still
ate meals of little Debbie's and
coca-cola and he was too small for his
prison jumpsuit and he kept it
outgrowing his shoes but no one could
give him new shoes because the prison
wasn't would only give him one pair of
shoes a year and social services was no
longer involved in this case this was
just a child in an adult system
why no picture in the book frankly
because I think my publisher felt that
he wasn't a sympathetic looking person
he wasn't white upper-middle class he
was a he's a kid and he is more
representative of the kids who are
filling the prison system today you know
he's had a rough past he often has that
that sort of that that tough stance that
I think a lot of kids take on in prison
and a lot of kids who grow up as he did
on the streets Jill why would we care
whether he was a sympathetic person or
not I mean well I know again back to the
picture thing
it's a tough it's a tough issue you know
I don't know that a lot of people want
to face this certainly in Ohio they
didn't and they still don't some people
don't want to face this the director of
social servant Children's Service is
there recently said why do we want to
open old wounds why point fingers well
the point is to understand what happened
you know Johnny Jordan didn't have to
murder he chose to and that is his
responsibility but there are reasons why
children kill and why we can prevent
this from happening in the future
I think that's very important I think
there's so many things to learn both
personally and also you know within the
welfare system about how to prevent
these these situations people don't want
to look at kids who murder be
because it's a it seems like a
horrendous awful and explicable thing
but what I'm saying is there are reasons
we often see stories of kids who just
suddenly erupt
you know the Columbine shooters are just
people kids across the country and they
we often hear that there was no reason
there was no trigger well oftentimes
those reasons are hidden in juvenile
files which are closed to the public and
I think that those privacy laws are not
protecting the children as they were
intended to they're certainly not
protecting people like the Johnsons who
took it
they're only protecting a system that's
failing why would your publisher Free
Press care whether or not this Johnny
Jordan was a sympathetic person I think
because it's a difficult it seems like a
difficult issue something that people
don't necessarily want to look at and
they don't want to care about what
happened to Johnny Jordan but I think
that Johnny is more representative of
the kids who are in adult prisons now I
think most of them have come from his
kind of rough background would you look
like he looks like a kid he when he was
in prison he was trying to put on weight
to make him look tougher so he wouldn't
get picked on as much but the weight
kind of fell into into fat you know not
a fat kid but certainly just not a
muscular man yet he's a child still he's
been working out a lot since he's been
in prison so now he looks a little
tougher he often sits and sort of a
tough inmate pose you know with his legs
spread like looking like he's ready to
pounce but he he still has a soft look
in his eye often times and he still
looks like a child have you talked to
him hundreds of times yeah why does he
talk to you
that's a good question and at first he
didn't want to talk to me at first he
wanted to get paid for participating in
the book and I told him that that I
wouldn't do that and then he was
reluctant he said what do I get out of
it and I said don't you want to help
other kids like you so kids don't wind
up where you are so why do I care about
other kids I don't care you're you're
stupid if you care about other people
like that
now that was the tough Johnny Jordan
that's the outward Johnny Jordan that
that you see on the surface there's
another side to Johnny Jordan which is
much more compassionate and gentle
there's only a part of him that's cut
off from his emotions my husband's a
journalist for the Washington Post he
was sent to Pakistan for three weeks to
cover the war and it was a difficult
time for me and Johnny called every
night reminding me to kiss my baby
goodnight and to make sure I wasn't too
lonely and Johnny had nothing to gain
from that the book had already been out
he had already read what I'd written and
it's not always a very generous and
oftentimes not sympathetic look at who
he is so there are many different sides
to Johnny Jordan and just as when you
look at him there are just many
different features he often appears
rough but there's often something very
young about him where is Johnny Jordan
senior and where is Johnny Jordan
juniors mother Johnny Jordan senior is
in prison serving about 40 years 40 to
70 years for the abuse he inflicted on
his children and his mother was in
prison for two years but she plea
bargained her way out of a longer
sentence his mother is often on the
streets now his father is serving the
prison time and his father I have to say
is the ugliest man I've ever met and I
don't mean physically I just mean
sitting down and talking to him
everything he says is self-serving he
told me that Johnny committed the murder
so that he could spend more time with
his father because he loves his father
so much we
because he went to present himself as a
good father and in fact Johnny and his
father were incarcerated in the same
prison at one point by mistake but
that's not supposed to happen and Johnny
said that he would when he saw his
father he didn't know why but he just
feel like throwing up and johnny is a
kid who had been through abuse but
either didn't recognize the abuse or
didn't want to admit the abuse either
the abuse was so normal and his family
that he didn't recognize it as abuse or
he didn't he tried not to remember it he
plays with his memory a lot he tries to
remember things the way he wants them to
be the mother is on the street for what
purpose she's in and out of you know the
drug she has some substance abuse
problems she's not a very uh you know
stable person have you met her only I
saw her briefly but she did not want to
talk to me for this book how many
children did those two have together
they had seven children and even before
johnny was born Social Services was
aware that there were problems in the
family and the parents I think we're so
fuddled I guess that might be the word
that they actually named one of Johnny's
younger siblings Johnny because they had
forgotten they had a child by his name
what's the age range of the seven
children Johnny is with the third he's
101 and he's 21 and his oldest sister
would be probably about 26 now and the
young is about five and where are they
all they're all split up they're all in
different places the two youngest are
with his step grandmother who also cared
for Johnny one of them is in juvenile
prison
the eldest is on her own with two
children of her own
most of them except for the eldest have
been in and out of different foster care
facilities and different juvenile
detention facilities
Johnny Jordan jr. has and I think I read
your book has been in five different
prisons or their more by now their five
now adult prison I don't prison why five
different prisons for the first time he
was in prison that had a juvenile a
branch for juveniles in particular and
and then he was transferred and put in
with adult inmates when he should have
been with juvenile inmates because they
try and separate them in Ohio although
it doesn't always work then he was in a
prison with his father and they didn't
recognize the father and son were in the
same prison until I requested an
interview and then they had to separate
them so he's just been moved all around
at first he had a very difficult time in
prison he was in solitary confinement an
awful lot because like most kids in
adult prisons they tend to lash out a
lot in fact once one of the first times
I interviewed him I was alone in a
conference room with him and before we
went into that conference room I saw a
kid who was incarcerated jump up and
grab the person who was visiting and the
guard took me aside and he said these
are the most dangerous criminals you've
ever met these these kids because they
don't wait until they're on the street
to get somebody back they just react at
the moment to whatever happens so you
have to be very careful in interviewing
them and if the day before one of those
kids and that environment had pulled a
knife on his former girlfriend and
grabbed her and it was a hostage
situation because most adult criminals
recognize if I do this I'm going to get
more time and I'll just wait till I'm on
the street again or they do it in a more
subtle manner
but the but a lot of these kids are very
impulsive and will just react how much
money is paid to a foster parent to take
a kid in ten dollars a day 12 dollars a
day very little very little
considering what they're up against so
you get some of the most caring and
generous people like the Johnsons and
some people who can't get a job anywhere
else and they're looking for any extra
income they can get how much race is
there involved in all this these are
these folks white or black well in
prison in adult prisons three-quarters
of the kids serving time in adult
prisons are black what about Johnny
Jordan
Johnny's african-american the Johnsons
were African American and go back to the
scene when the murder was committed how
old would you say mrs. Johnson was she
was almost 70 and I'm sorry she was 62
her husband was 70 and what were the
circumstances again how long had he been
in the home what time of day was it and
how did the actual murder itself happen
Johnny had been with the Johnsons for
three months he loved playing checkers
with mr. Johnson
he loved teasing and joking with mrs.
Johnson he felt very comfortable there
and they really liked him but they had
noticed some disturbing behavior they
were never told of of his past they were
just told that he needed a temporary
home for two or three days but those two
or three days stretched into three
months he had not been enrolled in
school by social services because they
kept expecting to move him the day of
the murder Johnny had found out several
days before that he was going to be
moved from their home and he was upset
about it
the day of the murder he woke up with
the churning in his stomach and this
feeling that he was going to do
something really bad and he didn't know
what it was again the date January 29th
1996
that's right I'm sorry and all day he
tried to to combat this feeling inside
of him he tried to change what he felt
he he thought he'd go out for a walk but
it was too cold to go out for his walk
and he called his his counselor several
times during that day paged him he said
jr. you better come get me I'm gonna do
something bad I don't know what I'm
gonna do but I wouldn't do something bad
and junior who like a lot of people in
his position was burned out he's got
dozens of kids on his caseload like
Johnny
Jr's operating out of where about what's
out of Toledo what's his name full name
Junior Robinson and he often takes you
know care of kids like Johnny in a
mentor type role often he's paid in this
case he was paid but he's also looked
out for Johnny when he wasn't paid and
it's a stressful situation you know
these kids call it all times a day and
night and it was taking a toll on him
and he was getting out of town for that
weekend so he said Johnny you know you
can hold on to you know wait a few days
I'll be back in a few days he thought at
worst Johnny might run away again the
Johnsons had also noticed
Johnny's troubled behavior and they had
called social services three times the
day before the murder asking that he be
moved from their home there was nothing
really specific that they noticed just
that he was aggravated and edgy and that
he was breaking their rules like they
had a rule against cursing and swearing
in the house and Johnny would would do
that and it wasn't like Johnny cause
Johnny had generally been sort of sweet
natured with them now Johnny's father
had also been arrested recently on
charges of abusing his children and
Johnny felt respond he always felt like
he had to protect his parents to take
care of his parents of all the kids in
his family he was the one who sort of
looked out for all the others and he
felt responsible for them so a lot of
things were going on inside of Johnny
but he didn't know he couldn't
didn't know the feelings inside of him
he couldn't identify them
you know for example Johnny doesn't feel
anger he just gets angry at something
and oftentimes he'll smile when he's
angry he doesn't connect the emotions to
how he's feeling and at this stage he's
15 he's 15
how much school was he had well he's
repeated several years of of fifth grade
he's up to I think eighth grade now I
made different schools he's been in
maybe six seven schools private public
mostly public he was suspended a hundred
and twenty times from the last school he
had been in for doing what for just
talking when he shouldn't have been
talking from being disruptive that sort
of thing
and yet when he was in a group home that
he liked very much where jr. was the
counselor he got almost straight A's so
you know he was very influenced by his
environment so we're back to the home
again and what time of day is it it's in
the afternoon now Johnny I've been
fighting this feeling all day and the
afternoon and he gets what he describes
as an evil thought stuck in his head he
walks into the room where mrs. Johnson
is watching Oprah and he he has this
thought hit her over the head just wants
hit her over the head he walks out he
he's trying to you know break this free
of this feeling but it's really churning
inside of him he waits longer and then
he says that he walks into the room
where mrs. Johnson is and he at this
point sees himself from outside of his
body it's as if he's in the corner of
the room the ceiling looking down at the
scene and he said on one shoulder on his
right shoulder he saw a little devil
like a cartoon figure and a red cape
saying hit her over the head just do it
just once hit her over the head do it
and on the other shoulder he saw a
little angel in a white gown biking the
cartoon saying no Johnny don't do it
don't
to it and they're arguing back and forth
so three times he walks into the kitchen
where his foster mother is preparing
dinner for him his favorite dinner when
he sees an axe by the stove by the wood
stove and he takes the axe in his hand
and twice he was able to turn and walk
out on the third time he hid her from
behind and on on the top of her head she
turned and looked at him she didn't say
anything but he he remembered her the
surprise in her eyes and he remembered
the surprise he felt and he said to me
later I never thought I had the guts to
do something like that I never thought I
could do something like that and then he
struck her something like 12 to 15 times
according to the coroner and her face in
her eyes Johnny said he hit her much
more many more times than that he didn't
realize how difficult it was to kill I
mean how how physically difficult and he
also said and he wasn't proud of this he
had no idea how good it would feel to
murder how good that rage would feel
he's not proud of that and he also said
he knew something was wrong with him
when he could watch her bleed to death
and not feel anything when he was
arrested by detectives they described
his confession as the most bizarre
confession they had ever heard it was
even inhuman considering the brutal
nature of the act but he did other
things besides just hacker to death
right he set her on fire and how did he
do that he poured kerosene on her the
idea was he kept hearing her breathe he
said he thought he kept hearing her
breathe the coroner believes that she
was dead before he set her on fire but
he was afraid she was breathing and that
she would tell what happened and he also
had this idea that if he set her on fire
it would all just vanish there would be
nothing left of her or of anything
where's mr. Johnson and all of us mr.
Johnson had gone out to get a space
heater because the house was cold it was
a very very cold winter
and he had gone out to get a space
heater while his wife was talking to a
friend in the house and the friend had
subsequently left so he in fact when he
was leaving he had a sense that he
shouldn't leave and he had walked back
towards the house and then he heard his
wife laughing and he left again so he
was driving back to the house at this
time when Johnny was you know pacing
back and forth after he'd set her on
fire he was still in a very agitated
state
and then Johnny walked out into the
night and he walked down the same road
that mr. Johnson drove up coming home in
fact they passed each other but neither
but mr. Johnson didn't recognize Johnny
was it dark at this point it was dark
and like most of these juvenile crimes
the crimes committed by juveniles they
happened between 3 & 6 in the afternoon
why is that the case the there is some
people believe it's because the kids are
out of school at that point so they're
free to commit the murders they're
oftentimes more Restless at that time
than at night so what happened when mr.
Johnson got home he knew immediately who
had done it he knew it was Johnny there
was no evidence linking Johnny to the
case in fact the only reason he was
arrested it was B or I'm sorry that he
was able to be brought to child was
because of his confession and he
confessed because he said he wanted help
but mr. Johnson got on the phone he
called he called the police he called
the fire department actually first
because of the smoke in the house and
mr. Johnson in his heart believed that
his wife was still alive even though he
knew she wasn't
it was a very poignant scene I think
from the description of his neighbors
and his friends there and from mr.
Johnson himself it was like he could no
longer breathe he knew his life had left
when you did how much of what you just
told us came from Johnny Jordan
description of the description of the
murder that came from Johnny did it come
to you or did it come in the trial it
came to me some of it came out and the
trial as well he had told his he had
also told his attorneys about the angel
and the devil and debating for him
whether he should do this and that it
was an evil thought that told him to do
this and his attorney tried to get
different a psychiatrists to evaluate
him to see whether he was fit to stand
trial and they had brought down in three
different psychiatrists and each of them
determined that these cartoon figures
were just an indication of an immature
conscience that they weren't indications
that Johnny was not fit to stand trial
at some point in your book you suggest
and I don't remember exactly how it
happened that Johnny Jordan did this
because of watching cartoons on
television I asked Johnny I said what
why why did you think of doing it this
way hitting her over the head because
Johnny had access to guns there were
different ways he could have done this
in fact in my research I found that
there was one other time when he had
thought of killing someone and that had
been a previous foster mother and it was
the same type of situation in which he
wanted to stay but he was going to be
moved and at that time he had a gun
buried in the backyard because she
didn't permit guns in the house and he
respected her but he had also thought of
hitting her over the head and said where
did you ever get this idea of hitting
someone over the head he said I don't
know maybe it was the cartoons or
something I said well did you expect
that she would just
died from getting hit over the head and
he said yeah I think I did I think I
would just have to hit her once and that
would be it and I could put her in the
closet and there wouldn't be any blood
or anything like that so he he was the
one who thought that perhaps it came
from cartoons he didn't know where he
got the idea but it was something that
stuck with him
how big a story was this in Toledo it
was pretty big just like every community
that faces these kinds of seemingly
inexplicable the murders these
horrendous crimes and that there was a
lot of outrage a lot of anger towards
Johnny and put him away and then let's
move on there was a lot of open wounds
right after his case they lowered the
minimum age at which a child can be
executed to 13 they changed the laws to
make it easier to prosecute children as
adults it really came down to wanting to
protect foster parents from these really
evil kids and you know that rather than
looking at who Johnny was and what
happened to him and why this happened
the the reaction was to change the law
so that we can put these kids away as
soon as possible for as long as possible
is this Lucas County okay that in Toledo
is inside Lucas County that's right how
many foster parents are there in a
County like that
that's hard for me to say and it
fluctuates after Johnny's arrest the
numbers went substantially down and a
lot of people complained when I wanted
to write this book you know nobody's
gonna want a foster parent and my
argument was no the real foster parents
out there know about these troubled kids
and they're begging social services to
be honest even mr. Johnson said that had
he known of Johnny's difficult behavior
and rough past he still would have taken
Johnny in I found that remarkable after
everything that had happened he still
would have taken Johnny in but he would
have been prepared he would have known
what to look for he
would have eaten known to make sure that
Johnny was getting some sort of
counseling so it's a you used it figure
somewhere the book about two hundred and
I don't remember that two hundred homes
are two hundred foster kids you know
what
how big a number of in that County how
many children were foster children I
don't know but I think it was about two
hundred foster parents and around that
time how many of them do it for the
money that's a very difficult question I
would say of Johnny's foster parents all
the ones that I interviewed did at least
partly at least mostly for the money
that's nineteen one of the foster
parents hit a knife under her bed for
protection
another hit a knife in her laundry
basket for protection how many of them
have multiple foster kids almost all of
them almost all of them
and how many of them talked to you how
many of the 19 forced to parents that he
had talked to you a number of them to
spoke to me off the record and several
of them spoke to me on background and
some of them would correspond it to me
but did not speak directly to me so I
think that with each of them there was
this sense of it could have been me you
know that's that's what they wanted they
wanted to find out for me information
about him rather than to explain what
their experience was with him what year
did you start this book I started this
in 80
sorry 97 so you're a year after about a
year after the night and in your own
life what was going on were you married
then I was yes I was married I had to
forget the date I was married 96 that's
embarrassing yeah
how old is your child man he's 14 months
and you had written the book mole people
the mole people what what year did that
come out that came out in 93 92 or 93
all about the people who live in the
tunnels in New York City right people
making their homes in tunnels under New
York what led up to all this where did
you come from what where did you go to
school I went to school at Washington
University in st. Louis and then I went
to Columbia Journalism school and I was
intern working at a newspaper and I was
working in some tutoring some kids and
one of the kids said that she had a
friend who lived in the tunnels under
New York and I didn't believe it so I
started working in soup kitchens and
networking in the homeless circles and
found out that there were literally
thousands of people living in the
tunnels under New York City and making
their homes there when you would go out
to talk to them and how many roughly did
you talk to the mole people that's
that's very difficult there were
communities of like under Grand Central
there was a community of over a hundred
people right there
it's not there anymore but and then
there were tunnels like under Riverside
Park where you'd get three or four
people living together and sort of
neighborhoods you go down into the
tongues
yeah what do you dress how'd you dress
well I was once mistaken for a homeless
person by a homeless person above crap
not that I intended to fit in it was
just like my boots and my pea coat was
missing a button and I wore my hair in a
ponytail you know what I didn't try and
fit in but I just wore the thickest
boots I could because I was so afraid of
that third rail and and it was mostly
wintertime when I was there so heavy
coats fear I it started off as an
adventure it really did I I just found
it fascinating and then as I watch
people die of everything from AIDS to
simple colds people unable to care for
themselves yeah in fact the fear hit
later you know when I looking at my son
I look into his eyes and I think was I
crazy
I could have missed out on this you know
and now now that I have his life to look
after and to look after my husband as
well I can't imagine doing it again what
did what what did what drove you to do
this where did in your own past is there
anything that connects on this my
father's a journalist he is yeah he well
he recently retired from los angeles
times his name robert toth robert toth
he covered national security
he was also foreign correspondent and we
lived in London and in Moscow during the
years of the Soviet Union and in the 70s
he wrote articles about Soviet
refuseniks and he had been threatened
and told not to write these articles and
he was arrested and
he was interrogated and he was sentenced
or he was accused of being a spy just to
prevent him from writing these articles
which I'm very proud of him for he
really stood up for what he believed was
an important truth to be told I found
that inspiring I was what did he think
when you're going to the tunnels of New
York and also for that matter
interviewing Johnny Jordan and going to
and into the prisons and stuff hey it
was pretty angry about the tunnels he he
threatened to break all my fingers to
prevent me from writing and to keep me
out of the tunnels but my little brother
told me I should do it why did he think
you should do it he said just do what
you always do don't listen and just do
it but then again he was that he was an
undergraduate student at Stanford so
like me he didn't realize how I think
bad things could get now and with Johnny
Jordan I think my father had a lot of
different feelings about it my father
works closely with me when I write these
books he's he's the toughest editor I
hope I'll ever have he's pretty tough
but and he wasn't he was nervous about
my association with Johnny but in the
end I think he understands how important
it is Johnny Jordan jr. calls you at
home collect
still how close do you want to get to
this young man or you're already you
know hundreds of hours into the
relationship
all right and our relationship changed
substantially after I'd finished the
book during the book I I purposefully
was cold to him I purposefully kept up
he had my number to call me collect
and I hadn't yet had my son during most
of this time and I felt that it was a
professional relationship in fact there
are often times I asked him tough
questions and he gets so angry that I
wondered if he'd ever call me back or if
that was the end but I had to ask those
questions and I had to really put it to
him and then after the book came out and
he said something to me he said you know
I I really don't want to be in here
anymore
I really want to be out but I realize I
could do this again and I don't want to
do this again I don't want to kill
somebody again it might happen but I
don't want that to happen and we talked
more and more and I realized there was a
type of self-awareness developing in
Johnny
just having some connection to the
outside world because everybody had
fallen away from him the only person
that he still kept in top and contact
was with his former attorney named Ron
Wingate and how did he get an attorney
because he had any money right it was
that he was assigned an attorney did I
read it the attorney wasn't paid it was
pretty much you know just 1,000 or 2,000
dollars for all the amount of work he
put into this case he put an astounding
amount of work into this case why wasn't
he paid it just because it was a
court-appointed lawyer and so this was
something that he you know he was
expected to take on this case and in
addition to his other cases but he got
very involved in Johnny's case he really
felt strongly he felt this could be my
kid you know if the situations were
different this could have been my kid
his other attorney felt very differently
he never felt that his stepchildren
could have become Johnny Jordans now
one's name Wingate went wind and Meyer
yeah when Kate's african-american and
Meier is white how did that have
anything to do with the relationship of
the two mr. Windgate got close to join
Jordan he's black and Richard Meier is
white
I don't think so I don't I really don't
think that Johnny notices color very
much I don't think he's that affects
them very much maybe it affected the
attorneys you know maybe you could
identity could the african-american
attorney could identify with the things
that Johnny was up against more than the
white attorney could I pointed out in
your book though that that mr. Windgate
made thousand dollars or whatever it was
but the attorney who went after the
money at the county level for mr.
Johnson made a hundred and sixty-five
thousand dollars mm-hmm because there
wasn't it mr. Johnson sought reform
within the foster-care juvenile justice
and mental health care systems he died
before any of those reforms went
anywhere and and with his death that the
move towards reform was dropped and
that's why I felt it was important to
continue because mr. Johnson wasn't
educated beyond the fourth grade and I
think that that affected his ability to
to get the the help that he needed to
get these reforms but he did have an
attorney who was a former social worker
who who was going to fight for these
reforms and trying to prove that the
foster care system had been negligent
and not telling or criminal and not
telling the Johnsons of Johnny's past
now it was really impossible to prove
that they were anything but negligent
and not telling the Johnsons that it
wasn't had what's the word it wasn't out
of cruelty that they didn't tell them it
was just negligence so there was an
out-of-court settlement for just under a
million dollars and the attorney
received a cut of that but mr. Johnson
died before he spent any of that money
and their desire he died of cancer but
it was really noticeable the decline
after mrs. Johnson's death he just
withered I watched him with her
he just had nothing left in him his
friends say he died of grief and it and
I personally believe that that's true
another thing you traced on the Johnny
Jordan's senior and his wife level was
drugs that it seemed that you were
saying that at the heart of the
beginning of the all the problems were
drugs
I think drugs and just a cycle of bad
childhood johnny jordan senior tiny
jardin juniors father had a difficult
past - he had actually also been in
foster care at different times his
mother was a prostitute his father was a
pimp he was illegitimate Johnny's mother
Marilyn Monroe at least that's what she
said her name was I told her husband her
name was Marilyn Monroe
she had also had a difficult past that
she wasn't willing to talk about and it
was assumed that there was a lot of
abuse in her past as well so there I
think that aside from the drug abuse
which is often a part of these difficult
childhoods that there's a there are
these cycles that are not being broken
of abuse and neglect of drugs of bad
parenting
abuse you've used that word several
times what kind of abuse well in
Johnny's case it was I think it was
certainly both physical but more
damaging I think is the emotional abuse
the power people have over their kids
the brainwashing they do to say you know
this is normal
these people are out to get us don't go
see a psychiatrist you know they're
gonna they're just going to try and get
us and if you open up at all to the
outside you're going to you're going to
kill me literally because they'll put me
in prison and people will kill me it's
an awful lot of responsibility for kids
the that kind of abuse I think is more
damaging and was more damaging to Johnny
than anything you could put him through
physically you have a lot of characters
in your book besides what we've talked
about so far who are the good good ones
and who are the not-so-good ones I think
this was also very inspiring in this
book the heroes the the people that were
working to save Johnny Jordans and we're
working against the system that was not
designed to help let alone save a system
that I think was creating Johnny Jordans
and they're working within that system
when you say system what are you talking
about juvenile justice mental health
foster care County based county level
city based all the way up how much
federal money is into this lots lots and
lots and it's just not being used
effectively how much state money's in it
lots to I can't put a number on it but
it's just not being used effectively
what about the children's services and
all anyway when all this starts say you
know you've got a Johnny Jordan jr. how
do they find out he needs a foster hmm
and who decides that oftentimes with
kids like Johnny
well with Johnny it was his parents were
were abusive and neglectful and it took
many many times for Social Services to
recognize that they had to be these kids
had to be taken away and by the time
they were willing to terminate parental
rights it was really too late for most
of these kids to be adopted who died who
did who decides the social worker the
social works for the children's services
and that is administered by the welfare
agency is that what you mean yeah County
based up for it it is County man where
do they get their money they get their
money from state federal and county lots
of money and like place like Lucas
County Toledo area I think enough to
raise these kids better than they're
doing they think we operate with you
know social services Children's Service
is not at all not at all wouldn't talk
to you about this no they did at one
point the director agreed to meet with
me me with two attorneys two of his
attorneys but that was it and he also
told the foster parents not to talk to
me I was able to get ahold of all of
Johnny's files from social services how
well it wasn't always legally I was able
to to get those files and certainly I
wouldn't have used them without Johnny's
permission or the Johnson's permission
but I felt that there were a lot of
truths that need to be told the truth
like the Johnsons had asked that this
child be removed for their home three
times the weekend before the murder and
you know there were people who needed to
be held accountable but most of all that
system that was protecting itself needed
to be held accountable they wouldn't
even give the [ __ ] the files to the
judge involved in the case they wanted
to withhold the files from the judge and
he had to absolutely order them a number
of times to give up those files why are
they doing this
they wanted to protect themselves they
wanted to protect their social worker
who
elected to take him out of their home
the home but they also wanted to be
absolved of any blame they wanted to
believe that this kid just went off and
that's what they want to present to the
public there was no way of predicting
that this kid was going to flip and
murder which is absolutely not true he
was tried as you said as an adult and
convicted as an adult for what kind of
murder was it aggravated murder and then
aggravated robbery and aggravated arson
and was there an insanity plea there was
there was an insanity and had Jonny
known that that's what he was pleading
he would not have pled insanity because
he didn't want anybody think he was
crazy no matter what that was the most
important thing to him that nobody
thought he was crazy so yeah so social
services and the juvenile courts what
did you find there well I found that at
one time his probation officer before
the murder took about a month before the
murder his probation officer had noticed
that Jonny was getting out of control
and wanted to put him in a detention
facility to do so he needed to appear
before a judge with the his social
worker from foster care the probation
officer and a mentor and they all needed
to be in agreement before the judge the
social worker had failed to show up at
that meeting so the move was thrown out
you know just like in traffic court if
the police officer doesn't show up and
so Jonny was put back into the Johnson's
home so I found that those three systems
were not working together
in fact in Ohio like in many states if a
kid is found to be criminal or
delinquent they can no longer enter the
mental health system and I think most
people would recognize that kids who are
just showing trouble behavior whether
it's abusing animals or assaulting each
other they need mental health as well as
some sort of you know juvenile justice
intervention they need these programs to
be working together and they're not
they're all working separately and
that's why these kids aren't getting the
help they need to develop emotionally to
the
the kind of conscience that we we we
think that they don't have when they
commit these crimes when this book came
out and when was the actual date that it
was published it was published in in
February of this year did the local
Toledo Blade do a story on this book yes
they did
did it make any difference I don't think
I think that it made a difference in
that it made people more aware of this
case I think that it's the the fallout
has been has been uneven some people are
very pleased that it's out in the open
some people are still angry why pick it
old wounds but actually the only person
that I know of who's angry is the
director of the children's services but
all of us needed to come out is there a
name on that director he needs it yeah
Dean Sparks he needs to be aware of
what's going on he I think he knows and
the fact that he wants to cover it up I
think is is really almost criminal let
me go back to have asked you this a
couple times but what is it about you
it's driving you to do this both the
mold people and the tunnels of New York
and this story on Toledo because this
didn't have to happen and because we we
can stop this from happening there don't
mister mrs. Johnson didn't have to die
for these changes to be made she did die
but as mr. Johnson said they're going to
be a lot more mrs. Johnson's out there
until we do something about this and if
we can tell these stories and be honest
about them if we can really look at
what's going on we can prevent them and
these kids are our greatest hope this is
a at the point at which we can change
things it's harder to change when people
are in their later years or even middle
years living in the tunnels under New
York and they have nothing to go back to
above-ground but these kids they have a
future and they know it
and all of the kids that I've talked to
they want to do right they want to do
good things they want approval they
don't want to go out and murder somebody
but they're not getting what they need
to develop into a healthy human being
and to me that's what's so important
that's why that's why these stories are
important are you driven because you
want to be a writer are you driven
because you want to have an impact on
the social system that's a good question
I don't know if I know the answer to
that I know that when I get involved in
these books I feel a real commitment to
them and because they give me so much I
learned so much about myself and about
what's going on around me I feel so much
more enriched knowing someone like
Johnny Jordan even and knowing mr.
Johnson he taught me things that that
still today I think about every day
every day and I want to present things
to people
I want readers to read what I have to
write and come up with their own ideas
their own conclusions a lot of people
who have read my books have actually
taught me things about things I've
written you know they've they've seen
other things that than I've seen and
that's important to me do you have a
next book in mind I have some ideas I
certainly hope there'll be a next book
but do you have an area that you want to
that you've thought about doing yeah
again I think it will be nonfiction my
father keeps trying to encourage me to
get out of the kinds of nonfiction I've
been writing about something a little
safer he says but I have some ideas our
guest has been jennifer toast and this
is the cover of her book what happened
to Johnny Jordan the story of a child
turning violent thank you very much
thank you